eh bien bon soir les amis et bienvenue
en abitibi région située à quatre heures
de route de outaouais là on a fait du
rafting la dernière fois on est arrivé
il ya quoi y'a deux heures on a eu le
temps de manger de boire un café de se
changer nous sommes en short cet après
midi au programme 6 du vélo dans les
montagnes de l'abitibi et que le rafting
et 10 coiffer les jours d'avant je
commence à être un peu fatigué mais bon
on va tout donner pour le vtt c'est la
dernière activité crevante bref de fixer
les go pro partout comme pour le rafting
et puis je vous dis à tout de suite sur
mon bike
[Musique]
ok les amis après cette petite bière en
étant seul avait ça fait quarante huit
heures mon gars c'est l'un des plus
beaux moments de ma vie on sait
inspectés pour voir j'en avais d'éthique
parce qu'on a on est un peu crevé mais
c'est cool parce que là on va un peu de
shit et is here je vous explique est
vite fait ce que c'est le val d'or de la
ville dans laquelle on est donc c'est
une ville située en abitibi et qui vient
essentiellement de l'exploitation
minière
donc c'est essentiellement des mines qui
exploite l'or est en fait derrière moi
c'est une maison typique qui a été
construit dans les années 1920 pour les
mineurs ce qu'elle est minée lors il
avait le droit d'avoir une maison comme
ça uniquement s'ils étaient en couple
donc quand et des beaux gosses étaient
très très avantagés à l'époque parce que
ça va aujourd'hui c'est que dans ces
maisons là il ya des familles qui vivent
encore et surtout il ya encore
énormément de gens qui travaillent dans
la mine dans la ville par exemple les
trois personnes à qui on a fait du vélo
tout à l'heure les trois travail dans la
mine alors pas dans la même il y en a
plusieurs comme j'ai dit mais les trois
vont bosser dans une mine ils ont
différents postes etc
et c'est assez fou quoi encore
aujourd'hui ça fait presque s'affaissant
pige presque qui vivent de
l'exploitation minière quoi donc nous on
dort dans une auberge que juste à côté
qui a pas cette tête l'américaine très
charmant et demain on va avoir la chance
d'aller dans une mine alors il y aura
pas de mineurs à côté de nous en fait
c'est plus utilisé est pure arnaque
[Musique]
les amis il est maintenant temps après
cette bonne bière et ce bon dîner on va
aller à la fête foraine du val d'or
voilà c'est parti bien sûr je vous
regarde en voie de forains pendant toute
la bande vidéo est magnifique
[Musique]
j'ai un problème bien passe partout qui
veut m'amener à la prochaine épreuve
sauf je suis pas dans fort boyard les
amis nous sommes actuellement dans la
grande roue de la fête foraine du val
d'or en abitibi avec ces gens qui m'ont
totalement suivi écouté ses hyper
enrichissant que vous rencontrez ce soir
je pense pas qu'il y aurait autant de
gens qui vont connaître et à la dette ou
c'était cool même offert les peluches
des trucs c'est hyper touchant
1000mercis on est prêt pour visiter la
mine demain et or à s'endormir sur de
belles notes à demain en visite à demain
au top
[Musique]
les amis avez-vous bien dormi le oui les
9 heures du matin je mets gay doit
enchanter guedouar sont les bienvenus
merci beaucoup
on est sur le site de la cité de l'or on
y va tout de suite on a su bien écouter
avant je crois parce qu'ils arrivent à
faire 8 degrés là dessous dont continue
sa vie des sous-vêtements qu'est ce que
c'est un signe sûr on est tous assez on
se trouve pas pour la ds un génial on va
ressembler indiana jones mon gars c'est
parti les amis on est dans la pièce sur
quoi se changer en remettent une tenue
comme ça et on va descendre
patrice crochet enfants sages des
galeries c'est comme ça qu'ils
récoltaient la roche
il avait des foreuses qui pèsent jusqu'à
75 kg tous nous avions
75 kg ça et des fois il fait monter des
échelles avec ça sur le dos le mec
c'était totalement déçu rang et
peut-être ça peut être intéressant de
montrer la salle à manger des mineurs
hyper spacieuse 5 étoiles mon gars et
voilà on a tous vu micro-ondes de
l'époque
n'est ce pas donc ça aussi aussi le
refuge c'est à dire qu'en cas de
problème un incendie donc ça fait
beaucoup de fumée etc
ils viennent se réfugier ici il ya un
téléphone pour contacter la surface et
ce qui est dangereux c'est que dans une
mini trail est toujours par deux
pourquoi parce qu'il ya énormément de
bruit et du coup si tu as un pépin des
petites galères tu des blessés ou quoi
tu peux pas appeler à l'aide entendra
pas qu'ils bossent par deux et quand le
matin avec la gueule de bois et décide
de faire une sieste d'une heure et bat
son pote est seul dans la mine donc
c'est assez dangereux donc morale de
l'histoire ne pas boire d'alcool avant
de travailler avant ou tout court d'air
faut pas boire de regarder on est devant
un wagon qui est binaire utiliser ça
c'est le premier wagon dans les années
30 le pousser à la force de leurs bras
et ensuite ils devaient les décharger à
l'aide d'une manivelle
tout était vraiment manuel 5 10 ans plus
tard ça avait déjà évolué il y avait un
moteur un gros moteur en galère ça il
est juste en face alors faut dire que ça
à la base c'était en plein milieu des
couloirs c'était pas du tout dans un
coin comme ça et ici on a un moteur
électrique
bien sûr petit port usb c'est on connaît
bien pour charger d'un iphone ça pouvait
transporter quatre wagons environ 2
comme ceux comme celui-ci mec rempli de
roche ça fait un maximum de roche pour
donner une idée dans cette mine lin la
valeur change selon la la concentration
en or des roches dans les mines et dans
cette mine là il était particulièrement
riche qu'il fallait cinq tonnes de roche
pour avoir 32 grammes d'or ce qui fait
une once de gars d'autres mines ça il
faut 10 tonnes 20 30 même des fois donc
cette mine était particulièrement très
très efficace attention imaginez ce sont
x 40 dans vos oreilles
[Applaudissements]
à
fini on peut un mec moi je délaisse les
bruits et aux forts et sourd que
j'apprenne avec ça je n'aurais jamais pu
très dans une mine c'est fou tu
t'imagines sans fin car on paye plus les
p'tits potes avec leurs fourreaux à côté
c'est terrible longue aujourd'hui mais
qu'on ferait une journée dans une mine
on a besoin d'être mourir il faisait ça
pendant des années donc c'est hyper
respectable les mineurs ou des chefs si
vous êtes mineur déchiré
[Musique]
les amis bienvenue encline à huit c'est
ici qu'il va se terminer notre séjour au
canada tetris clément qui n'abritent ça
veut dire tous pour tous pourquoi se le
dire pour tous parce que c'est un centre
communautaire et associatif qui a été
créée pour rassembler les autochtones
les autochtones sont les amérindiens
d'heure on a vu quelques-uns à la fête
regagnèrent soir en fait il n'ya pas en
france je viens très peu en france des
amérindiens
ok logique parce que c'est des
amérindiens du coup on va se reposer là
vous voyez un tipi là-bas habitat
traditionnel des amérindiens préserver
culte hippiques amérindiens au ski
c'est la fin du voyage le nombre de
conneries qu'on dise voilà écoute mec ça
est très reposant va être en pleine
nature
on va dormir dans un tipi une nouvelle
fois c'est tout ce qu'on peut pour
terminer ce voyage c'est très reposant
tu me suis clairement c'est parti dans
ton manier dans tes jambes à la fatigue
est là
la fatigue est là haut up feat drake là
on a vraiment envie de dormir
[Musique]
les amis c'est la fin de cette troisième
et dernière vidéo au canada n'aura vécu
beaucoup de choses très positives on a
pu rencontrer les gens on a pu découvrir
des régions que non jamais découvert on
a vu la ville on a vu la campagne on a
fait des sports extrêmes
une habile on a rencontré frédéric
philippe quévy serge andré au [ __ ]
vous allume la lumière de seconde
moustic landes bref on a fait de très
très belles rencontres durant tout le
voyage que ce soit des gens parmi vous
où les gens qui nous ont aidé à vivre
ces moments merveilleux qu'ils ont guidé
fier montréal canada en tout cas merci
d'avoir suivi les vidéos je sais pas ça
vous a plu parce que je les publie que
dans un mois mais j'espère que oui c'est
le cas n'hésitez pas à les aimer tout
tout comme ça d'affilée clac clac clac
merci clément d'avoir accompagné pendant
ce voyage merci mon gros merci à tous et
à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo au
revoir
[Musique]